well I I do understand that to a certain
extent because I sometimes I just wanna
I feel like I should take you out on a
YouTube show sometimes because you think
that's bad
uh I'm take this with a grain of salt
Buffalo New York you guys have some of
the most untalented human beings on
every kid ass every time I do a show at
that college they go what is your worst
show I always say at Buffalo New York
the only thing they have is buffalo
wings that's it that's what they that's
what they're known for
that's what it was creative really good
so absolutely amazing yeah talent wise
zero so I did this talent show right and
I was supposed to be a judge yeah and I
specifically remember this one kid cuz
he did super well so he's Chinese kid
and he's doing this act where he's uh
seeing a lady Gaga song so mind you he
has a very thick Chinese accent he goes
I'm like busting up laughs I'm grabbing
everybody else I'm like yo this [ __ ]
kid is dope I'm cracking up we go to the
back we're telling you a points I give
him a perfect ten everybody looks at me
they're like what are you doing I was
like dude he was a [ __ ] great
comedian he yeah he was seeing for real
and you've laughed in his face robbed
that so the whole time he was singing
seriously [ __ ] I was if I was there with
you
I would've got arrested no I would have
died from laugher but you know how the
guy said I'll see you at the circuit so
yes kid audacity he comes up to me after
the show he goes oh I heard your thing
we're singer together maybe we should
collaborate sometime and I'm like what I
was so appalled you know and another
thing I'm like better than him as a
human being but it's like Josiah we're
all equal of course as human beings know
we are we're all equal as human beings
but a lot of stand-ups can't even go to
auditions like like Mencia told me one
time Carlos Mencia years ago because I
can't go bro because like we all you
know I mean like we're equal but as a
comedian you know um you know he did
they can't handle so I have to sit there
when you're auditioning for some people
that you know people like Gilbert true
I have no credits but yeah but you know
my point is is that you hate
no credit you know we should collaborate
I just started going to auditions this
year yeah yeah you know after we had
that conversation that you're talking to
me about acting it kind of gave me a
little fuel yeah so thank you very much
for that and I started going to
auditions and then I realize how
emotionally damaging it is it's one of
the human experience
I have never you know first of all tell
me okay so number one I don't know what
my agent I just met him but I don't
think he knows who I am as a person
what agency is it by the way you can see
that right Abrams oh I love it with
Avery was four years when I was earlier
yeah so I don't know what any I'm not an
actress I don't know what any of this
[ __ ] is so I go every single audition
the first four that I had right when you
walk into the room I expect people to
look like me yeah ten black ice one
Asian guy every time I'm Korean yeah you
not figured this out yet yeah you know
and then there's an emotion of sometimes
you feel like you kill it right yeah and
then you walk out they don't really
laugh and you hear somebody else's
auditions like ass and they're laughing
their ass off yeah harmony wants to go
open door in like you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and they closed the door and just
leave yeah and I didn't know there was
like a scabbing period that people were
telling you about eventually you just
scab over and you just started getting
numb he never gets he hasn't scabbed
over yet yeah that hasn't happened to me
either so I twenty years
I'm not scared I feel it hurts him so
destroys for weeks it haunts him he has
one bad audition every rule everything
even the ones that you can't like yeah
no I get destroyed because here's what
it is is is that I work on it right I
mean I felt like I never we work on I
memorize it I spend the day waking up
because Joey's like some early morning
that like no one was like he's even away
but like I show up at 8:00 9:00 10:00 in
the morning somewhere in Santa Monica
you walk in and when you have a bad one
it's just you think it's my time you
know and I'm not mad at them I met it
myself
sometimes for not hitting it you know
sometimes like I've auditioned for
things where I remember like one time I
ran out you're in the car and I and I
didn't get it but I just know I there's
nothing I couldn't have done better like
I killed it listening to me is a little
weird too because they expect you to get
it right that in there it's like
sometimes you know for me it's like I
could kill this part but I can't do it
in one go yeah you know and I've had
that feeling where I saw somebody who
got the part and I'm like dude he's
[ __ ] ass are you [ __ ] kidding me
right now you know what the thing here's
the thing though at the end of the day
it's this is that when I when it's nine
black guys and one Asian that's a good
situation
oh okay because net now you're showing
them an option right when you imagine
being sitting there watching nine black
eyes in a roll doing the same lines
mm-hmm and then having you walk in and
do it then it's like oh wow that's
different okay and usually a lot of
times you get that part it's when it's
50 Asian right and you're seeing
everyone from you know Brian tee to you
- I can - everyone at then it's like I'm
not gonna get this mmm there's so many
other options you know I mean there was
I did something very stupid to where I'm
as I'm going I'm learning about how to
audition better and better so there's
one audition I didn't realize that I'm
really bad at script reading and
everything I read it as a comedy what
it's not it was a drama yes and I read
the character as a comedic character and
so this so she's reading lies as she's
taping it right and immediately I'm
expecting her to say it with like an
upbeat live type of thing as she goes so
what happened to that person I'm like
yeah cuz my character was goofy as [ __ ]
yeah and the only thing I could do was
play it out as a goofy character she
goes well thank you that was interesting
my car like this I lost the job like I
had the best audition and I lost it
at the end what do you when I was
talking as myself yeah I killed it right
and there was a black eye he was a fact
I and he was sitting there and he's
laughing so hard and then when you're
after the audition when they go they see
when they keep asking you questions so
where you from after you read you know
it's good where are you from off from
San Diego man and he's like oh dude I
love sent you know you're talking you're
like and I was close to him and we're
just laughing and we're talking and then
I poked his Bell I go fatty yeah and
then it the whole room I just go fatty
and I hooked up in the potty I think the
comet would have been okay I think the
Pope was the one if I was the director
and I was having a good time and some
guy did that I'd be like oh that's funny
[Laughter]
I mean it's that same feeling when you
have that person like quote-unquote
beneath you say we're gonna do the
circuit that's like oh I have all I mean
the worst human experiences of my life
have been an audition
there I have PTSD like this thing I got
this thing that this to show him do now
I do not disappoint you know me I don't
think I could get it I don't know I
don't know I think it now it has to be
you just have a unique quality of I want
to do it or not you know I mean because
don't let me audition yeah yeah I mean
because even though two years ago I did
a pilot and she made me go in I remember
what happened
we were outside NBC believe you good
that's what she said right name that's
what yeah yeah it was early in the
morning we're screaming we're evening
outside cuz it's like I didn't [ __ ] is
he oh he's always like you have to come
with me
I didn't wake my ass up and then 7:00 in
the [ __ ] morning just for you
to bail while we're outside the studio
you know what I mean like I was hurting
my eyes were burning
yeah I walked into the car lon yeah it
was a whole thing you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but finally you know you wanna see
me walk you gotta go you want to see me
Bob
he's like I'm [ __ ] Bob and he got the
job no that's awesome but if she hadn't
done that when I got the job good
together I was alive I'm gonna fall
asleep in then this she's yell at me I
already know I can yell that all the
time I'm just kind of I've scabbed over
from that
[Music]